resilience is if you're on a high you
just got that you know plaque on YouTube
maybe you just hit a record you got your
first a th000 subscribers maybe you got
the silver plaque in the mail you hit
100,000 you just had you just got
monetized you maybe just had a viral
video you're you're on some Peak emotion
maybe you not only are doing well on
YouTube but you came home and like your
spouse your partner's pumped and like
they were super encouraging you just
been like hitting gold it's just you're
on some momentum the key is that even if
you have these big wins that yes you
celebrate yes you enjoy it but how
quickly do you get back to Baseline and
get back to work elasticity back to not
letting success go to your head not
letting success make you prideful make
your ego inflated and maybe make you
feel entitled to the victory that you
just won we've learned that yesterday's
home runs do not win today's games so
resilience is even on a high how quickly
do you get back to Baseline and then
similarly we've all been there where
maybe it's like the last 10 videos just
haven't hit the YouTube channel ad
revenues down the views are down your
business is down and then maybe you have
maybe you're experiencing some chronic
pain you're facing a Health Challenge
you're facing some struggles with some
aging parents you're just in a season of
intense challenge how quickly can you
get back to Baseline acknowledging those
emotions processing them pray through
them getting planted in church being in
counseling like doing all the things but
as a leader you still have to show up
and get results as a leader you may get
some horrible news right before you have
to step on stage or step on camera and
actually deliver so ultimately
resilience as an attribute becomes one
of those critical components of staying
consistent through every season the
highs and the lows staying stoic a
strong character
is one that will not be unbalanced by
the most powerful of emotions either
high or low two things number one I've
had too much coffee today number two if
you have not seen our free master class
yet you're going to love it if you're
serious about growing your YouTube
channel just go to think masterclass.com
for a onehour deep dive on demand
YouTube strategy class it's sick and uh
I'm going to go refill my coffee hope to
see you on the class